Well, that gas might come out.
So when you poke the mud at the bottom,
bubbles of gas, come out in principle,
this contains a trace of phosphene, but you won't be able to see any fostering,
but what it's not often the professor doesn't experiment
very recently papers been published that has caused huge
excitements. Astronomers have detected the gas.
Phosphine pH three on the planet, Venus,
but what's really caused excitement is that they've said this could
be the sign of life on the planet,
which is really surprising because up till now,
people have thought Venus is really hot and unpleasant.
So life couldn't possibly exist.
Phosphine molecule pH three is as Brady likes to say
the older brother of ammonia NH three,
because phosphorus is underneath nitrogen on the periodic table.
So I am at home. I don't have all my molecular models.
You've got to imagine this black Pitt is a pair of
electrons and the molecule has phosphorous with three
hydrogen atoms round it in the actual molecule.
These hydrogen atoms are a bit further down.
There are two ways of making phosphene.
You can make it by reacting a metal phosphite that's a
compound of a metal, say zinc or aluminum and phosphorous.
And if you react it with this with acid, phosphene bubbles out.
Usually it comes out slightly impure mixed with a
molecule P two H four,
and this P two H four has a strong smell of garlic.
It also has the property that if it's exposed to oxygen in the air,
it's immediately burst into flames.
But pH three itself does not catch fire and
can exist for quite a long time in the atmosphere.
Until I read the paper about Venus,
I didn't realize that phosphene is also present in the Earth's atmosphere.
Phosphene is really quite poisonous,
but it's at such low concentrations in the atmosphere.
It can't possibly harm you phosphene is at a very, very low level.
Phosphine on earth comes largely from decomposition of plant
matter in the mud at the bottom of poems,
the bacteria turn the phosphorus, which is found, for example,
in the DNA of the plant material,
DNA contains a lot of phosphate.
This is turned into phosphine phosphine is free to soluble in water,
so it can bubble out together with the Marsh gas,
the methane that is the major product of these bacteria.
There is actually a story, which I'm not sure is true,
but is sounds fun.
Which is that in the old days, by old days, I mean seven,
800,
900 years ago when there was no street lighting and
people were walking through marshy areas,
they sometimes saw strange lights,
which in English called Willow the wisp, these strange lights,
they thought were houses.
And therefore they walked into the Marsh and were drowned.
And the suggestion is that perhaps it was phosphine coming out with its
impurity, with the Marsh gas and setting the meat thing on fire.
But this may be complete rubbish.
Industrially phosphene is made by reacting white
phosphorous. You will have seen our video on white phosphorus with peat,
burning it to produce huge amount of light white phosphorous can
react with alkali and produce phosphine phosphine is used
industrially for two major applications.
One in the electronics industry.
The other use is fumigating clothes to kill parasites.
Let's get back to Venus the first point,
which was a real surprise to me that Venus is not the first planet
that pH three phosphine has been discovered on.
There's very good data for phosphine being discovered on Jupiter and
Saturn,
where the Cassini space probe used the
absorption of infrared light to detect phosphene in the atmosphere.
How did they discover it on Venus? Because they weren't using a space probe.
They were using telescopes here on earth and the way that they discovered it
was due to the absorption of light.
When the molecules rotate now,
a molecule like phosphene can rotate round
and round. And when it rotates,
it can absorb energy and rotate faster.
And the absorptions due to the rotation,
give rise to many them,
many lines in the spectrum at very long wave light,
almost in the microwave region, millimeter wavelengths.
There are a lot of these absorptions and they have varied sharp,
which means that even if you have all sorts of absorptions due to other
molecules, there will be a gap where you can see the absorption of phosphene.
If it's there.
I should say this model is difficult to rotate because it squeaks
the Earth's atmosphere absorbs a lot of this radiation.
So you can only record the using a telescope that is very
high in altitude.
So there isn't much air above it between you and Venus.
And one of the key pieces of evidence was they sort of got the same result
from different telescopes,
which meant there wasn't a factory nearby releasing phosphine into the air.
If phosphenes already been observed on Saturn and Jupiter,
why aren't people saying there's life on Saturn and Jupiter,
but there might be on Venus.
And the reason is using modeling of atmospheric chemistry.
You can produce a good mechanism,
how phosphene could arise in Saturn and
Jupiter. The problem with Venus,
which has a very dense atmosphere with a lot of carbon dioxide,
not very much hydrogen, it's difficult,
if not impossible for the authors to construct a model that would
explain why the phosphene was there.
The problem is that once the phosphene is formed,
it will drift up in the atmosphere.
And Venus you ought to know is close to the sun.
So there is a lot of UV light from the sun that can quickly destroy
the phosphene.
So there must be something that is generating this phosphene
continuously to match the rate at which it's being destroyed.
The authors write in their paper,
that they can't think of another mechanism,
and it could be due to some form of life in their
favor.
The bacteria in the bottom of poems are anaerobic
bacteria that they operate in the absence of oxygen.
And there is no or very little free oxygen on Venus.
We don't really understand entirely how the bacteria
make this material on earth.
So one would have to go into considerable speculation to
work out what might make it on Venus.
They may be right,
but it's important to be quite skeptical and think they
could be some different explanation. I'm not an atmospheric chemist.
So I'm not going to tell, you know,
some brilliant explanation because I don't know who won,
but I know enough about chemistry to reserve my judgment
and say, they wouldn't be surprised if quite soon as somebody comes up with an
alternative explanation,
of course it would be thrilling if they were right. And there is life on Venus,
but they really strange life because it will be floating in the
atmosphere. Some considerable distance above ground level,
perhaps 30 kilometers up chemists,
as opposed to people who are trying to fumigate clothes,
don't use phosphine very much.
I've only done one reaction in my career with a phosphine
derivative.
That's a compound between phosphine and iron pH three itself is
a slightly strange compound. All chemists know about it,
but if you ask them about the use, they would probably have to look it up.
Phosphine is used to kill rodents like rats.
Now you don't guess them with phosphine,
but instead you give them food that contains metal
phosphates. This food smells a bit of garlic,
but this doesn't seem to put the rats off from eating it.
And when they eat it,
the FOSS Fides in the food zinc, phosphite aluminum,
phosphite reacts with the acid in the rat stomach and generates
phosphene, which then poisons the rats. How do you stop it?
Poisoning other random holes. And there's quite a cunning twist.
The commercial rat poison usually contains an antimony compound,
which makes people violently sick and most animals.
And you mix this in with the rat poison.
So you might ask why doesn't the rat gets sick as well,
because if I add the rat poison or you did,
you'd immediately vomit and it'll all come out again.
And it turns out that rats cannot form it.
They don't have the physiological mechanism to be sick.
So if you learn nothing else from the phosphene on Venus,
it's the fact that rats cannot be sick.